ينضم الينا من الخرطوم دكتور محمد ابراهيم
عبد الرحمن المتحدث باسم وزاره الصحه في
السودان اهلا بك معنا الدكتور يعني هل
هناك
موافقه من قبلكم على الارقام التي تعلنها
نقابه الاطباء
والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله يحييكم
ويحيي المشاهد الكريم
وحي الشعب السوداني ونترحم على الذين فاضت
ارواحهم الطاهره الى باريها
ونتمنى العجله الشفاء للجرحى
ونحيي القطاع الصحي العريض القطاع
[موسيقى]
الحكومي والخاص والمتطوعين الذين يمثلون
ملحمه وطنيه في العمل في تقديم الخدمات
الصحيه في المستشفيات والمراكز العقيده
القيمه الخدمات الصحيه تحت هذه الظروف
بالنسبه لسؤالي دكتور لو سمحت نعم نعم هذه
الارقام التي طرحت
من من الاجسام التي سميتموها منظمه
نظامه اطباء السودان على الواقع لا يوجد
ما يسمى السودان في السودان لا يوجد جسم
بهذا المسمى
اما الارقام التي طرحت من منظمه الصحه
العالميه فهي ارقام غير صحيحه منظمه الصحه
العالميه ايضا تستغي معلوماتها من منظمات
ليس لديها قاعده بيانات حقيقيه في النظام
الصحه في السودان هل هم يتحدثون عن نظام
الصحه خرطوم ولا في جميع ولايات السودان
ال 18 ولايه هل يتحدثون الصحه العالميه لا
تتواصل معكم يعني انا ما بدي افوت بموضوع
الاشتباك مع النقابه لانه صار معروف بس مع
المنظمه ليش ما بتستقي معلوماتها من وزاره
الصحه
يسالوا عن هذا الموضوع اين
انتم معهم بالتقارير اللازمه نحن نفيدهم
هذه المعلومات متاحه في موقع وزاره الصحه
الاتحاديه وموقع وزاره الصحه
وهنالك باسمه اذا تصحح الاتحاديه
ونحن نطلع على هذه القنوات مرارا وتكرارا
بس عفوا يعني انه في منظمه صحه عالميه وفي
وضع حرب يعني انتم تقولون له روحه على
جوجل يعني لحتى تشوفوا المعلومات واجبكم
انتم كووزاره انت تبلغوهم بذلك
اخي الكريم نحن ابو عمر مفتوح ونحن الجهه
الرسميه والدستوريه والمسؤوله والمسائله
هذه الارقام طبيه الان على ارض
الواقع التي تعتمد
غير مسؤوله وغير مساله
طيب من وزاره الصحه الاتحاديه التي تتحدث
عن جميع السودان وزاره الصحه لا تخرطوم طب
شو ارقامكم انتم
عدد الجرحى
الذي قادر عن
نقابه الاطباء السودان هو عدد قليل لا
يمثل الجرحى ولا الجرحى في السودان لانهم
ليس لديهم قاعده البيانات حقيقيه
طيب نحن واحد النقابه حكيت عن 2175 طب هذه
الموثقين يا دكتور ما هو باي حرب هيك بصير
بيحكوا عن الموثقين واللي مش قادرين
يوثقوهم ما بيحصروهم يعني ولا انتم قادرين
تحصروهم يعني على الاقل بيعطوا رقم مبدا
عن المحصوره في المستشفيات
اذا هم اذا ما عندهم اهليه للحصر اكثر دقه
يبقى مهما يكونوا مرجعي انا اتكلم عن
الاليات بما يلي المستشفيات والمراكز
معلوماتهم عن المستشفيات خاطئه
ما ارقامكم الرسميه الان بخصوص القتلى
بعيدا عن الاشتباك السياسي بين الطرفين
الان بينكم وبين نقابه الاطباء
المهني انا لا اتحدث
بارقام مهنيه
حتى يعني كيف يكون ذلك مهنيا وانت لا
تعترف حتى بنقابه الاطباء في بلدك
كيف يكون ذلك مهنيا وانت لا تعترف حتى
بنقابه الاطباء لا يوجد على الجسم شرعي
اسمه نقابه اطباء لا يوجد
يعني كيف لا يوجد الاطباء نقابه عريقه جدا
في السودان طول عمرها مسؤوله عن كانت يعني
ثورات كانت تقوم على ظهرها احيانا في
السودان يعني كيف الان تنكر دورها
هنالك نظام معتمد لتكوين النقابات
هنالك نظام معتمد لتكوين النغبات هنالك
اربع ايام تظهر في هذه القناه اللجنه
التمهيديه لنقابه اطباء السودان نقابه
السودان المكتب الموحد لنقابه اطباء
السودان اللجنه المركزيه لنقابه اطباء
السودان هذا
طيب ان كانت هذه الاجسام على ارض الواقع
المتاحه نحن نناشدكم عبرها نناشدها نناشد
هذه الاجسام عبركوا ان ينزلوا الى
المستشفيات والمراكز الصحيه اذا كانوا هم
جزء من هذا النظام الصحي اذا كان هذه هذه
الصوره وصلت وهي برسم نقابه الاطباء اذا
الان وهم مخولون بالرد عليها انشاؤه عبر
منابر العربيه تمام
وصلت وجهه نظرك هي برسم نقابه الاطباء
الان ان ارادوا الرد عبر منابر العربيه
الان عدد القتلى لديكم كم في الوزاره
الذي جاء الى المستشفيات العامله عدد
المصابين 3
1288 في المستشفيات الحكوميه و17 في
المستشفيات القطاع الخاص هذه الاعداد
بالارقام السجلات الطبيه
تحدث عن الذين جاؤوا مستشفين في
المستشفيات
الوفيات 206 وفاء موفقه هذه التي اتت الى
المستشفى
بس هذه ايضا انت تقول انه غير نهائيه لانه
لا يمكن الحصر الان يعني هذه ارقام غير
نعم لانه يعني تبدو قد يبدو العدد اكبر
بظل الوضع عم بيعيشوا البلد
طيب بموضوع انه 69% من المستشفيات
المتاخمه
لمناطق الاشتباكات
من المراكز الصحيه التي تعمل الان 51 مركز
صحي مرجعي يقدم خدمات الحالات البارده
والامراض المزمنه على على
مستوى تبع محليات الان في مناطق امنه من
مجمل 81 مركز
قالت النقابه انه 69% من المستشفيات
المتاخمه لمناطق الاشتباكات بدك تسمعني
دكتور محمد لو سمحت
دكتور محمد عم تسمعني قالت نقابه اطباء
سوداني انه 69% من المستشفيات المتاخمه
لمناطق الاشتباكات التي قامت بحصرها
متوقفه عن الخدمه هذا كمان مش صحيح
اسال سؤال هذه النسبه
كم عدد المستشفيات التي مثلها المقام
65% من كم مستشفى
من المستشفيات المتاخمه لمناطق الاشتباكات
بكل الخرطوم يعني والخرطوم بحري واندرمان
واضح الكلام هذه عدم
مستشفيات ولايه الخرطوم 134 مستشفى
على القطاع العام والقطاع الخاص 54 مستشفى
القطاع العام و 81 مستشفى القطاع الخاص
وهنالك 11 مستشفى تتبع للجيش والشرطه
والامن والجامعات غير محصوره في 134
مستشفى
التي تعمل الان بكفاءه
الحد الادنى الذي يقدم الخدمه الطارئه
وشبه الطارئه لجرحى الحرب والارض المزمنه
هي 95 مستشفى
جيدا ولكن ليس بالسوء الذي تتحدث عنه نق
ابه قادره على تقديم الخدمات الصحيه للوضع
الذي يحمي الحياه ويقدم الخدمه الخطره
وشبه الخطره على وسائل التواصل يموتون
بسبب قله الادويه السودانيه
بنداء قواعدهم ان كانت موجوده على الواقع
ان يذهب الى المستشفيات طيب ومن نرى على
وسائل التواصل انهم يموتون بسبب نقص
الادويه
بينما النقطه الادويه هذا ما نقراه على
وسائل التواصل انتم تنفوه صعوبه في الحركه
لانهم كده هنالك مناطق يوجد بها اشتباكات
وكروه فر لا ننكرها ولكن ليس هنالك النقص
في وجود الادويه المستهلكات هنالك
تعثر وهذا
وهذا في ظروف الحرب يعني وجهه نظركم ايضا
وضحت بعدما اشرنا الى ارقام وتقارير نقابه
الاطباء وهذه وجهه نظر وزاره الصحه في
السودان التي يمثلها اذا من الخرطوم دكتور
محمد نعم عدد مستشفيات ولايه السودان 811
مستشفى في ولايه السودان الان هنالك 16
ولايه في السودان امنه نعم
انهيار غير وارد ولايه خرطوم تمثل 15% من
مجموع من مجموع صفات السودان دكتور محمد
ابراهيم عبد الرحمن المتحدث باسم وزاره
الصحه في السودان من الخرطوم شكرا جزيلا
على وجودك معنا في هذه التغطيه متواصله من
العربيه ولانا لقاءات اخرى ان شاء الله
نتمنى ان يصبح الوضع افضل مما يقوله
الطرفان
في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر
الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات